Trump gave what I think was probably one
of the greatest speeches of world
leaders given you know it's got to be up
there with like Churchill Gettysburg
Address is the night the United States
killed the leader of Isis Trump comes
out of the Situation Room at like
midnight in the white house and he walks
down that [__] tunnel like he's and
gives a press conference like he's given
a post-game NBA just goes
Abu bakar
al-baghdadi is dead he died like a dog
yeah
I need to change one word of that that's
what he opened with
and then he did 40 minutes the speech is
40 minutes the meanest [__] talk you've
ever heard in front of the whole world
Abu
we could hear him crying and I said
let me tell you something Abu karate
cried quite a bit I wouldn't have cried
crybaby bag daddy that's what we were
all calling